many terms have changed their meaning
over the past few years diversity racism
oppression woman 10 years ago the term
woman was used to describe someone who
was born with a vagina had double X
chromosomes and was as emotionally
stable as Japan during a tsunami
nowadays being a woman is something
anyone can be just as long as you buy a
wig wear a dress and threaten to destroy
anyone's career who disagrees with you
the same thing has happened to the term
far right when I was growing up far
right meant people who were white
nationalists hated ethnic minorities and
openly supported Hitler and they were
never shy about telling you they were
racist in fact they were proud of it I
lived in a part of South London which
had a very real problem with white
nationalist groups such as the BMP and
the national front growing up in the
shadow of white supremacist groups had a
profound effect on my life my mom is
from Venezuela she wanted to call me
Francisco
haeo in English is Francis and Hae means
part of the vagina that breaks during
sex because we lived in an area where
racism was rampant my dad insisted that
my name should be Francis and I'm so
grateful to him because going to a South
London state school was much easier now
that I had the name of a middle class
white woman I was gender fluid before it
was cool the good thing was that my mom
never really understood the whole
politics thing I remember she once got
handed a leaflet for the BMP and asked
him if they had one in Spanish nowadays
the term far right has evolved to anyone
you disagree with Donald Trump Nigel
farz Boris Johnson Liz truss pretty
Patel swell braan I doubt Hitler would
approve of sella braan a brown woman who
married a Jewish man therefore producing
Brown Jewish kids and for those nerds
going at Francis jewishness is passed
down through the mother's side therefore
they're not Jews I'm no World War II
historian but I doubt Hitler would have
said you're not Henry you've got a point
they're not propa Jews let them go and
it's not just people the guardian have
come out and said things like exercise
is far right now I've had a few PE
teachers in my time who've shown some
fascistic Tendencies one PE teacher once
demanded I do 10 press UPS in 60 seconds
10 press ups only the SS would demand
someone do 10 press UPS in 60 Seconds
this is the sort of body fascism that
Geral would have approved of although
the Nazis were National socialists and I
don't think I've ever seen a socialist
who can do more than five press UPS the
guardian also claimed the countryside is
racist and of course it is you don't see
many black sheep there do you but
there's an important point to all this
because if everything is far right then
nothing is which is a very real problem
because the far rights still exist and
they are of course still a danger so
when you newspapers like the guardian
tell me the far right are on the rise in
Germany as someone who Bears more than a
passing resemblance to a Jewish man who
happens to be halfway through a
transition I start to get a little
nervous if they're going to start taking
away the juice I'm going to be in the
back of the van because no one believes
that my mom is Venezuelan and even if
they do I doubt those are the type of
genetics they want hanging about the
place plus it's not as if the Germans
don't have a history of this stuff every
time I see a German and I hear them talk
about nationalism I always see them
doing this no you must put a hand down
you must put it down even though it
feels so right and beautiful and natural
and so power if father land is behind
you put it down and now I'm seeing a
whole host of far right parties become
ever more popular across Europe and I'm
getting concerned because a lot of those
boys that Embrace fascism back in the
30s a little too quickly for my life in
take the French whose resistance to the
Nazis melted faster than one of their
cheeses at room temperature never ever
trust a Frenchman only joking I don't
trust anyone that speaks French and that
includes the belgians Flemish isn't a
language it's basically angry gargling
all of these parties are talking about
limiting immigration prioritizing their
citizens and have anti-islam policies
Marine Le Pen has spoken openly about
banning women from wearing the hijab
which she says is a symbol of a
totalitarian ideology I don't agree with
Banning the hijab I think adults should
be allowed to wear what they want
telling people what they can and can't
wear strikes me as authoritarian but I
also believe that immigration is
currently unsustainable and needs to be
brought down in some polls 40% of French
people have said that they agree with
her on certain policies does that mean
40% of France is far right or does it
simply mean that they've had enough of
mainstream political parties who they
feel have abandoned them many of her
economic policies would be classified as
left WI a whole host of these parties as
sweeping to power across Europe or at
the very least becoming serious
contenders and I'm torn because I think
it's great that new political entities
are challenging the status quo which has
become stale and lacking in ideas but I
also don't want people to be told what
to wear and since no one can agree with
what far right actually means what
happens when we get someone rise to
prominence who actually is far right
what do we do then we do the only thing
can do go on social media and moan about
it the only problem is New York time
articles talking about why separating
Black Sheep and white sheep is modern
day fascism will be far more popular
because writing about nonsense will
always engage people far more than
telling the truth which is why my next
monologue will be about why naturous
ands are one and the same thing 6
million views stay tuned before you go
let me tell you about a powerful new
longevity supplement that has got a lot
of people excited including the FDA who
are trying to get a key ingredient in
this stuff reclassified if you watched
our recent interview with Tim Urban you
might remember he said we should be
talking about longevity and Longevity
science researchers like the biologist
David Sinclair have recently made some
incredible discoveries on how to
mitigate or even slow down aging Al
together and that's why I'm using Verso
I'm actually 64 years old Verso is a
company that translates these incredible
scientific breakthroughs into products
that hold the potential to increase your
longevity and one of their products I
take every day is called cell beinging
cell beinging helps combat aging by
increasing something called NAD Plus in
your body NAD is arguably the most
important molecule in your body high NAD
levels improve your metabolism repairs
damage DNA and increases energy
production in your brain immune system
and muscles but as you grow old your
body's NAD levels go down and you can't
take NAD as a supplement because it's
too big for your cells to absorb that's
why Verso cell being contains nmn
Resveratrol and TMG these three
molecules work together to increase NAD
plus levels look up nmn and FDA you'll
find some interesting reading about why
they want to reclassify it if you want
to read more about all of the research
then check out the reference link in the
description of this video plus Verso
publishes third party testing on every
batch of its products to guarantee that
you're getting exactly what you're
paying for so if you want to join us you
can get 15% off your first order by
going to
v.o that's
b.so and use code trigger to save 15%
off your first order if you like this
monologue then you're going to love
comedian exposes woke Hypocrites click
here